later today we will start to learn the
results of the biggest upgrade to
Seattle's iconic Space Needle since it
opened back in 1962 the renovation
started last September when this 2,000
pound work platform was hoisted 500 feet
above the city since then around 150
construction workers have been working
20 hours a day six days a week to give
the structure some new vertigo-inducing
features is this good CBS Sunday morning
said sleek and got a tour at the top of
the site before this weekend's reopening
to the public it's to Seattle what the
Eiffel Tower is to Paris Horning six
hundred feet into the clouds this famous
saucer in the sky has been assembled the
Emerald City ever since it was built
welcome to the future it was the
centerpiece of the 1962 World's Fair the
vision of a space aged future but having
just turned 56 Seattle's beloved Space
Needle had been quietly enduring a
midlife crisis and architect Allen
Maskin was put in charge of giving it
what he calls a space lift Panico
systems electrical plumbing elevators
everything it just needed some TLC it
was time for it to actually get some
attention futzing with existing
architecture is always a risk especially
when its iconic so Baskin brought in a
consultant there it is one of the only
people left who knows the Space Needle
inside and out Gary Noble Kurtis yeah
you could take these drawings and build
another Space Needle right now 81 years
old he's one of the Space Needle
original structural engineers those are
his original hand-drawn drats
brings back a lot of memories I'm
looking at these trusses and remembering
when I designed those things put
everything up here oh it was all you
yeah yeah pretty much now but as
beautiful as it turned out even he
admits it was a rushed job the time
frame was what was really killer on the
thing how long did you have 13 months
just 13 months and all of this happened
out of nothing right right there are
features he and the architects wanted to
include but didn't have the time the
money or the technology to do
but today Alan Maskin has all three an
army of more than 150 construction
workers has been humming almost around
the clock trying to make the aging Space
Needle as sharp as a giant tack again
it's the largest investment ever made in
the Space Needle in fact back in 1961 it
only cost about five million dollars to
build the whole thing this renovation is
costing more than 100 million no one
ever said the future was gonna be cheap
it's a construction project that's 500
feet in the air you might as well be in
outer space the aim was pretty simple to
improve the view to make this platform
in the sky feel less like a building and
more like a cloud going from this to
this it's like we've we've widened the
lens in your eye so that you can see
much much more than you ever could
before to do it
48 glass panels each weighing a ton
we're carefully hoisted some 520 feet
straight up some of them guided by a
remote-controlled jetpack of souls to
help counteract the winds off Puget
Sound
[Music]
high above waiting for them to arrive we
found the project's field superintendent
Sonya Miller this you ever get old you
know no I could no it's always been in
my back yard the Space Needle so to
actually be here and doing this is it's
uh it's incredible a lot of the workers
here are local even the specially
designed robot that puts the glass in
place was assembled piece by piece up
here it's not just the observation deck
that's changed the rotating restaurant
has to now instead of just looking out
diners will be able to watch Seattle
pass beneath their feet making this the
world's first spinning restaurant with a
37 ton see-through floor you can see
these wheels here that actually will
rotate we're keeping all of that visible
how fast will it go
it goes I think it takes about 45
minutes for the entire rotation so an
entree all the changes won't affect a
view of the Space Needle though from the
ground you have no fear of heights
clearly no no no but up here the
experience for visitors is totally new
which has Sonia Miller bursting with
pride and when you're out on the
observation deck and you watch them and
they're backing up and leaning backwards
and you see the fear in their face and
they're holding on to their family
members I mean it's fun it's fun too
it's mission accomplished the space
medals mission though hasn't really
changed think about it may not be a view
of the future anymore but it's still a
testament to the possible for CBS this
morning Lee count high above sienna well
he clearly has no fear of heights no he
did not there they say you know it's the
closest thing to going to outer space
and he takers I like I want to go you
mean to outer space or the space needle
Space Needle no yeah I just don't
understand you're eating lunch and also
you're looking down and you can eat so
you need Dramamine and you need and yeah
just don't you mix on to I would think
it's going so slow that it's okay but
it's it's not the rotation that concerns
600 feet in the air while I'm eating my
pasta okay new slash don't look down ya
have to eat like this to be continued